students from Stoneman Douglas High
School are returning to class today you
can see students arriving for a half day
of modified classes two weeks after they
fled from a gunman on campus 17 students
and staff members were killed on that
Valentine's Day the school district says
there is now enhanced security at the
school but they are not giving any
specifics the massacre led survivors and
students from all over the US to
organize a call for tougher gun control
laws Adriana Diaz spoke to students and
teachers ahead of Stoneman Douglas High
School's reopening she is outside the
school in parkland Florida
Adriana good morning good morning both
students and teachers are anxious about
going back to school today and one
teacher told us that grief counselors
will be in the classrooms of victims who
passed away to provide support for
survivors I think everyone's a little
bit nervous ago it's gonna be a huge
just rush walking in returning to school
was all 15-year old sophomore Liam
Kernan could think about as he ate
dinner with his family last night but he
says he's not afraid actually tomorrow
is the beginning of change and we will
be the people to do it
Liam along with more than 3,000 other
Stoneman Douglas students will attend a
half-day of 24 minute classes extra
security and counselors will be on hand
we just aren't quite sure yet what the
new normal is ap psychology teacher Lisa
Chauvin has taught at Stoneman Douglas
for 26 years we're not really sure what
to expect because everyone is coming
with a different experience
some students were directly involved in
the events of that day
we're all human we're all in this
together and we're going to go through
the process of healing together building
12 the crime scene is blocked off by a
fence covered with posters of support no
one will be allowed inside the school
board wants it torn down and a memorial
built in its place I'm just hoping it's
gonna be a normal day but I think
there's gonna be a somber mood senior
anisha Sarah Polley
lost her close friend Carmen Sentra in
the Valentine's Day Massacre she'd
always brightened everyone
J'son now you know she's not here I'm
still trying to fight the fact that this
happened because I'm still in disbelief
what's her school mascot the Eagles you
can't say that without smiling I mean
it's such a good mascot for us honestly
I mean maybe a Phoenix would have been
better since out of the ashes we rise
and at this point I've never been
prouder to me an eagle today is anita's
17th birthday she told us she's thankful
there's no lunch period so she doesn't
have to sit without her friend Carmen
the school returns to a full day of
classes next week Gail thank you